schön dass Sie dabei sind so liebe
Zuschauer dreimal werden wir noch wach
dann ist endlich migrationsgipfel im
Kanzleramt also nicht dass da irgendein
Durchbruch zu erwarten wäre nein aber
danach kann man vielleicht auch mal
wieder über was anderes reden im Moment
dreht sich wenn sie drauf achten die
ganze deutsche Politik ausschließlich um
Migration sogar wenn der Kanzler nach
Afrika fliegt wie gerade ja
ja natürlich ging es auch da wieder um
rückführungs Abkommen und so langsam
merkt man dem Olaf den Stress auch an
also das ist jetzt nur meine Meinung
aber ich finde wenn du mit Nigeria und
Ghana nur zwei Länder
besuchst kannst du dir die Namen schon
merken zunächst mal die Beziehung
zwischen gana und Deutschland sind
gut
jo m im Satz
weggenickt besser als auf der Autobahn
ne leider wirkt auch der Kanzler beim
Thema Migration inzwischen wie ein
Getriebener und macht mit beim großen
herte Überbietungswettbewerb
spiegeltitel haben sie bestimmt gesehen
Scholz will endlich im großen Stil
abschieben ja so jetzt müssen wir nur
noch Länder finden jetzt müssen wir nur
noch Länder finden die ihre Leute auch
zurücknehmen und schon geht's los
kleiner Haken bei großen Ankündigung es
müssen dann auch Taten folgen ja das
gemein die Leute fragen dann tatsächlich
nach
was heißt denn im großen Stil und was
bringt das neue tolle abschiebegesetz
konkret gute Frage gleichzeitig werden
trotz der bald per Gesetz beschleunigten
Abschiebepraxis laut Innenministerium
nur rund 600 Abschiebungen mehr pro Jahr
möglich wow 600 wahrscheinlich haben
mehr Leute am Gesetz mitgearbeitet als
damit abgeschoben
werden Erwartungen wecken und dann nicht
liefern ist das Dümmste was man machen
kann Christian Lindner und Marco
Buschmann anderes Beispiel fordern diese
Woche für bestimmt bestimmte
Asylsuchende die Senkung der
Sozialleistung auf
Null warum nur auf Null können wir den
nicht was
wegnehmen ist doch der neue Stil die
Ampel lässt sich ernsthaft ein auf einen
ekligkeitswettbewerb mit der AFD wer
könnte den wohl am Ende
gewinnen ja wer sonst wer sonst meine
Damen und Herren ist egal der pullfaktor
muss jetzt weg Deutchland ist viel zu
attraktiv wir müssen jetzt alle ganz
schnell miese Bewertungen für
Deutschland schreiben bei tripadisor ja
das wä die Lösung so
so laut Migrationsforschung sind die
wahen pullfaktoren Rechtsstaatlichkeit
und die Chance auf Arbeit Geldkarte
statt Bargeld ändert gar nicht so viel
oder anders formuliert stellen sie sich
so vor ein Supermodel bleibt auch dann
attraktiv wenn es fl trägt und
Deutschland bleibt auch dann attraktiv
wenn wir unsere Sozialleistung
einstränken das heißt Deutschland kann
seine highhills Anlassen Gott sei Dank
meine Damen und Herren ja nur noch über
Migration reden ohne echte Lösung
anzubieten macht die Leute wahnsinnig
und das merkt man die Stimmung kippt ins
hysterische dank der üblichen
Verdächtigen hallo Bildzeitung ja vor
allem vielen Dank für euer tolles
Deutschland Manifest das den
Zugewanderten mit 50
im herbergsvaterton erklärt wie der Hase
hier bei uns läuft hab es gesehen mit
Punkt 9 z.B wir sagen BITTE und DANKE
DANKE dafür oder Punkt 33 deutschland
ist ein Land der
Griller nach einem Picknick im Park
nehmen wir unseren Müll wieder mit aha
ich würde gerne noch ergänzen Punkt 51
wir spielen gerne SC und rufen dabei
regelmäßig es hat sich schon mal einer
Tod
gemischt oder Hosen runter Buben raus
solche Sachen ja den hat die Bild wohl
vergessen zum Glück aber an Punkt 34
gedacht der ist echt Messer gehören bei
uns in die Küche und nicht in die
Hosentasche sehr gut völlig richtig
wobei warte mal ich bin überzeugt Bayern
und Deutschland wä sicherer wenn jeder
anständige Mann und jede anständige Frau
am Messer in der Taschen halten
D ja wir würden den hupsi ja abschieben
aber es gibt leider noch kein
Rückführungsabkommen mit Niederbayern da
machst du nichts ausgerechnet Flugblatt
Hubert beklagt jetzt Antisemitismus
durch Zuwanderung der traut sich was
viele Politiker unterstützen die
bildaktion darunter auch Carsten
Linnemann von der CDU wir brauchen eine
Hausordnung für Deutschland sehr gut
oder da riecht man förmig das boherwachs
im Treppenhaus ja sich ans Grundgesetz
halten reicht nämlich nicht mehr
Deutschland kriegt endlich eine
Hausordnung Vorschlag jedes Mal wenn
einer seinen Asylantrag in der
Ausländerbehörde einreicht gibt's
zusätzlich einen pflichtvortrag und zwar
durch einen ausgebildeten
klischeehausmeister so dann pass mal auf
Sportfreund bei uns in Deutschland gibt
es Regeln erstens wir lassen unser
Fahrrad nie im Flur stehen zweitens wir
reden während der Fahrt nie mit dem
Busfahrer und am allerwichtigsten wenn
wir hier zum Grillen eingeladen sind und
man ist hier immer irgendwo zum Grillen
eingeladen dann bringen wir
Kartoffelsalat mit undw guten mit zu
viel Mayonnaise los probieren ist aber
vegane Mayonnaise oder ich gebe dir
gleich vegane
Mayonnaise nur so geht Integration mit
der nötigen Härte ja es gibt
muslimischen Antisemitismus bei dem
müssen wir dringend dagegen halten aber
angesichts einer ohnehin grassierenden
wir gegen die Stimmung die Muslime
grundsätzlich zum Problem ja zur
Bedrohung zu erklären das geht gar nicht
hier Beispiel Friedrich merärz twittert
Deutschland könne jetzt nicht auch noch
Flüchtlinge aus Gaza aufnehmen denn
Zitat wir haben genug antisemitische
junge Männer im Land verstehen sie
Flüchtlinge aus Gaza gleich Antisemiten
das ist quasi die Definition von
Rassismus ja das hilft keinem wir
brauchen fand ich sehr subtil wir ist ja
nur ein Vorschlag was er da macht hilft
keinem wir brauchen konstruktive
Debattenbeiträge stattdessen zählt der
Mann seit Wochen wie viel Tage vergangen
sind Olaf Scholz den deutschlandpakt
ausgerufen hat wir haben heute Tag
42 des deutschlandpaktes heute ist wenn
ich richtig rechne Tag 46 heute ist Tag
53 wir haben heute Tag
64 des
deutschlandpaktes Tag 65 des
deutschlandpaktes ja sehr gut Friedrich
fleiskärtchen in Matthe würde ich sagen
s heute hat er den Kanzler getroffen wir
sind gespannt so kann man diesen März
noch toppen Logen kann man das Jens
Spann einer der ja vielleicht tausend
besten Gesundheitsminister die wir je
hatten möchte Achtung irreguläre
Migration auch mit physischer Gewalt
stoppen völlige Verrohung bertrix von
Storch ist damals wenigstens noch auf
der Maus ausgerutscht sie erinnern sich
span hat jetzt sogar die erste
nichtichthilfsorganisation gegründet
nennt sich Ärsche ohne Grenzen
ja sehr guter Name physische Gewalt
fordert einer der es nicht mal schafft
die Migration in seinem eigenen Büro zu
begrenzen Markus eenberger fragt ob ich
als
Generalsekretär könnten Sie vielleicht
oh gehen sie schnell durch haben wir
hier noch Besuch während wir gehen sie
durch ja gehen sie durch aber schnell
sonst gibt's aufs
Maul der Jens beim Deutschlandtag der
jung Union hat sparen übrigens Lösung in
der Migrationsfrage als Zitat letzte
Patrone in dieser Frage bezeichnet
sensibel gewählte Metapher würde ich
sagen da arbeitet einer offensichtlich
am neuen
Image tagsüber ist da ein harmloser CDU
Spießer aus dem Münsterland doch wenn es
Nacht wird patrouliiert Jens Spann ganz
allein die komplette EU Außengrenze und
sobald er da irgendeinen illegalen
Einwanderer erwischt poliert er ihm
höchstpönlich die Fresse zurück bleibt
nur sein Erkennungszeichen die mit
steuerkohle viel zu teuer eingekaufte
ffp2 Maske sehen Sie Jens clud van span
in the dark span rises wir werden ihm
viel verzeihen
müssen ja demnächst im Kino ab
18 SP
so ist natürlich unsere Kommunen müssen
entlastet werden und langfristig hilft
da wohl nur das Auslagern der
Asylverfahren in wohlgemerkt sichere
Drittstaaten kurzfristig helfen z.B
funktionierende Ausländerbehörden nur
ein Viertel von denen ist bei uns
digitalisiert ein Viertel ja
das das ist der Flaschenhals auch beim
abschieben alles was ich Bund und Länder
gerade so den ganzen Tag ausdenken auch
am Montag bei dem Gipfel kann nur
klappen mit schnelleren Behörden die
Realität in Deutschland sieht allerdings
so aus alles schlägt hier auf ein
Mitarbeitender ist hier für bis zu 3500
Akten verantwortlich die Frankfurter
Ausländerbehörde sitzt derzeit auf sage
und schreibe 15 000 unbeantworteten
E-Mails ja und da sind die Mails von dem
Prinzen aus Nigeria noch gar nicht
mitgerechnet meine Damen 15 000 endlich
mehr Mitarbeiter in diesen Ämtern das wä
eine Maßnahme konkret stattdessen gibt
der Kanzler weiter den Hypnotiseur sie
verstehen schon wir schieben im großen
Stil ab machen wir zwar gar nicht aber
glaubt's mir einfach wir bauen 400 000
Wohnungen im Jahr stimmt auch nicht und
fünf Windräder am Tag ja Probleme
abräumen mit griffigen Überschriften und
hoffen dass keiner nachragt Methode
Scholz halt aber selbst die hat
offensichtlich
Fans Holger Stockhaus ist Vorsitzender
und einziges Mitglied des ersten Olaf
Schulz
in seiner Freizeit guckte am liebsten
die Reden seines Idols eneriepris so ein
geiler Redner wir gucken nichts anderes
mehr Hammer wieeder das macht
oder Holger Stockhaus lebt streng nach
dem schulzprinzip das heißt Probleme
lösen indem man entschlossen über sie
spricht ich habe das einmal
durchgerechnet wenn jeder von uns nach
diesem Abendessen nur fünf Teller oder
Besteckteile abräumt dann können wir als
Familie unsere abräumziele schon um
20:35 erreichen und das muss unser Ziel
sein danke
Schatz deine Dreckwäsche liegt hier
wieder überall rum und das können wir
als Gesellschaft so nicht länger
hinnehmen deswegen schlage ich vor dass
wir heute den deutschen wäschepakt
ausrufen ich sage wenn jeder seine
Wäsche selber direkt wegräumt ja dann
mach das doch warte ich bin noch nicht
fertig wenn jeder seine Wäsche direkt
selber wegräumt dann können wir der
Nachfeld ein ganz anderes Schlafzimmer
hinterlassen inzwischen schläft das
Ehepaar sogar in Olaf Scholz betwäche me
neuen deutschlandtempo beim
Geschlechtsverkehr wird die Ektase
grenzenlos sein spätestens 2045 wirst du
so die endgültige Befriedigung erreichen
das habe ich mir als Ziel fest
vorgenommen Scholz Fan wird immer mehr
eins mit dem
Kanzler jetzt bitte nicht dein Ernst was
denn ja
gehur ich werde von nun an jeden Tag
fünf verschiedene Frauen bei tinder
Treffen das muss mein Ziel sein ich
nenne es Projekt
doppelbums
Stockhaus ja V Olf scholzub so meine
Damen und Herren Kriege sind wir uns
einig waren schon immer furchtbar aber
Kriege in Zeiten des Internets legen
noch eine horrorschippe oben drauf Hamas
Terroristen stellen ihre Morde ins Netz
influenzer die normalerweise
Lippenstifte testen erklären den
nostkonflikt und all das gucken dann
Kinder ja zwe dritt der 14 bis
29-Jährigen nutzen Social Media
regelmäßig als Infoquelle gott stehe uns
allen bei ja die aktuelle Fake News und
propagandaschwäme ist jedenfalls kaum
noch zu ertragen schon ab 13 Jahren kann
man sich auf tiktok ein Profil anlegen
wirklich überprüft wird das allerdings
nicht das heißt auch Kinder gucken zu
wenn quereinsteigerlehrer Arafat Abu
Chaka gelernter
Clanchef Nachhilfe in Geschichte gibt
ich rede wirklich von dies zionistische
Regime dieses das ist vergleichbar mit
Adolf Hitler ich sag dir ganz ehrlich
für mich ist sogar Adolf Hitler besser
als
Netanyahu ja da sitzt selbst Hitler in
der Hölle und denkt
what das hat er nicht wirklich
gesagt ja mein Reden seit Jahren wir
müssen das Internet umbenennen interböse
ja der sprechdurchfall gerade dieser
sprechdurchfall war letzten Sonntag im
Livestream auf tiktok zu sehen und und
wird aktuell von Berliner Staatsschutz
geprüft was gibt's da zu prüfen immerhin
ist im August in der EU der Digital
Service act in Kraft getreten
Internetkonzerne müssen bis zu 6% des
Jahresumsatzes als Strafe zahlen wenn
sie nicht entschieden oder schnell genug
gegen Hetze und Fake News Vorgehen sehr
gut finde ich sehr gut ja auch auch mehr
Transparenz wird damit eingeklagt und
das ist
aktuell nötiger denn je dieses Video
hier z.B zeigt nicht etwa ein Raketen
Einschlag sondern Feuerwerk von
Fußballfans in
Algerien und dieser Clip stammt sogar
aus einem
Videospiel ja und ich bin auch gar nicht
Olli welke sondern Giovanni
Zarella einige von euch hatten es
gehofft ne ja ja ja reines Wunschdenken
plus natürlich das Problem mit der immer
besseren KI der künstliche Intelligenz
jeder lei kann so aus seinem
Kinderzimmer für inzwischen schmales
Geld eine Lüge
machen und immer mehr Bilder sind kaum
noch als Fake zu erkennen für den
Amateur das
z.B ich verstehe nicht warum sie lachen
so sieht das aus wenn ich die offen
trage Fake News Flut überall deswegen
ist es absolut richtig dass die EU da
jetzt mal hart durchgreift ja finde ich
richtig gut kann man ja auch mal
erwähnen es wird sonst immer nur
rumehackt
dem europabächen kann man sie auch mal
loben und ich sage mal so wenn bestimmte
Leute sich über dein Gesetz ärgern weißt
du du hast alles richtig gemacht Elon
Musk denkt offenbar über ein Ende seines
Twitter Nachfolgers Ex hier in Europa
nach auslöser sei die Unzufriedenheit
des Tech milliades über das neue
digitalgesetz
DSA der kleine Elon ist traurig und
unzufrieden wie schön ja um sich wieder
zu beruhigen hat er erstmal Dropbox
Netflix und Getränke Hoffmann gekauft
ach komm andererseits wer redet noch
über sein blödes X oder Twitter völlig
wurscht tiktok ist der heiße Scheiß
besonders bei Kindern und Jugendlichen
so wie erkläre ich das Phänomen tiktok
jetzt unseren
stammzuschauern sie kennen doch die hör
zu
oder ich muss gar nicht schreien ach so
gut sag wir mal so wenn es eine
Fernsehzeitschrift für tiktok gäbe dann
wä das nicht die hör zu sondern
natürlich die scroll durch und dann
hätte die jede Woche so ca 900.000
Seiten ja bisschen unübersichtlich und
da steht dann z.B 15:1
exhibitionistische Katze völlig schamlos
oder 15:02 Uhr Vollidiot trinkt großes
Glas Tabasco da sieht man dann halt wie
ein Vollidiot ein großes Glas Tabasco
trinkt und andere Vollidioten freuen
sich so dann wieder praktische
Lebenshilfe um 15 D was hilft heute
wirklich gegen
Maulwürfe ja zum Beispiel Lebenshilfe
tiktok gehört bit Dance einem
chinesischen Konzern der im Zweifelsfall
auch unsere Daten Präsident Schi also
der chinesischen Staatsregierung geben
muss das juckt unsere Kinder aber nicht
wirklich und das wiederum liegt an
unserem Primaten Gehirn das auf billige
Belohnung aus ist wissen sie tiktok weiß
nämlich inzwischen sehr genau wie wir
alle ticken mit jedem Mal swipen hoffst
du darauf jetzt kommt gleich das coole
Video auf dass du den ganzen Abend
gewartet hast was du deinen Freunden
zeigen kannst also diese Wischbewegung
nach oben die endelt eindeutig so einer
so einem Zielen an so einem Hebel von
einem einarmigen Banditen ja so schnell
geht das mit einer Wischbewegung nach
oben kommt direkt der nächste Inhalt bin
ich ja froh dass das beim Fernsehen so
noch nicht möglich ist denn sonst wäre
es ja auch ein bisschen einfach für den
Zuschauer das Interesse bra Scheiße
Steffi jetzt läuft daspekte das will ich
auch
nicht dann zwe zurück tiktok was für ein
idiotenmedium
übrigens Aspekte heute um 23:30 Uhr
falls bümmermann nicht wieder so brutal
überzieht aber aber nicht nur die Hamas
lieb tiktok auch Rechtsextreme sind
große tiktok Fans die nutzen das Medium
längst als
rekrutierungsplattform und wissen ganz
genau wie man Filter die Rechten Content
suchen austrickst aus eigentlich
harmlosen herzemojis bastel die dann z.B
die Farben der Reichsflagge oder diese
zwei Blitze die stehen für die SS also
die Schutzstaffel im sogenannten Dritten
Reich und dieses emoji hat sich bisher
für mich eigentlich immer gemeldet oder
gewunken wie süß sie dachte echt ihr
wint ein Nazi zu das ist ja toll
ebenfalls beliebt unter rechten ist das
feueremoji aber das z
Bücherverbrennung der NAZ Regenbogen
ganz wichtig nur mit
Brauntönen und natürlich das niedliche
hitlinhorn
oh ja spannende Frage wie schützen wir
unsere Kinder vor sowas reden wir drüber
mit dem ich behaupte fruchtbarsten
Mitarbeiter der heuteh mit dem
erfahrenen fünffachen Vater Olaf
Schubert meine Damen und
[Applaus]
Herren
schön dass du da bist weißt du
eigentlich was deine Kinder im Internet
machen und wie erklärst du ihnen die
Gefahren z.B auf Social Media ich ich
hoffe zu wissen was sie machen mit
erklären kommt man ja nicht weiter
sondern man muss sich dann wirklich mit
den Kindern hinsetzen ja ich nehme mir
die 5 se
Stunden am Tag und wir ziehen das dann
auch wirklich ernst durch ja also da
gibt's keine Süßigkeiten sondern
wirklich nur ein Bier und
dann merkt man schon ja es gibt auf
tiktok eben wirklich es gibt Rechte
Inhalte es gibt auch Inhalte mit Gewalt
dafür gibt's allerdings keine
Pornografie
leider ja es ist halt nie alles
beisammen
und natürlich ja geht's ja in erster
Linie aber darum wie kann man die Kinder
schützen unterstützen bei dem was sie
selber ins Netz stellen und da herrscht
ja ein enormer Konformitätsdruck ja also
so durch diese
Schönheitsideale und was mir wirklich
Angst macht ist halt es gibt ja diese
diese Beauty Filter ja und meine Kinder
äh nehmen die nicht und ich
ja wo ich sage seid ihr wahnsinnig ja
also na ja
ich sag mal so bei der Tochter ist er
noch okay die kommt mehr nach mir äh
aber der Sohn der hängt vor der Linse
wirklich wie ein nasser Lappen und dann
wird gemobt und dann sage ich ja zurecht
ja so der tiktok Algorithmus weiß durch
deine segewohnhiten irgendwann alles
über dich und tiktok verkürzt gerade bei
jungen Menschen die
Aufmerksamkeitsspanne wie steuert man
dagegen
hä aufmerksamkeitspan ach so war ja ewig
die Frage
die Aufmerksamkeitsspanne ja tiktok
steuert ja selber gegen denn man kann
die Clips ja in doppelter
Geschwindigkeit kommen oder ja die
werden direkt zu angeboten das würde uns
ja auch mal gut tun doppelte
geschwindig ja aber es ist natürlich so
der der Algorithmus weiß irgendwann
alles und ich ich schaue ja immer so
Beiträge über Porzellanmalerei im
Albanien des frühen 17 jahrhunderts ja
also mir geht's danch zum kotzen aber
dem dem Algorithmus habe ich es gezeigt
ja also wirklich voll von hinten und man
kann schon was machen also ich denke
prinzipiell tiktok ist besser als sein
Ruf ist ja jetzt nichts man wird jetzt
davon nicht krank ja maximal stirbt
Gehirn
ab aber auch nur ganz langsam das jetzt
nicht so wie der Arzt sagt sie haben
noch einen Tag zu leben und ich habe sie
gestern nicht erreicht
ja das war z.B ein Witz aus der hört zu
meine
Damen ein großes Thema ist ja jetzt auch
ich sprach schonüber die KI man kann die
Stimmen von ent Menschen perfekt
fälschen die bewegbilder gibt's auch
Olaf Scholz der arme musste diese Woche
unfreiwillig Werbung für die Bildzeitung
machen wie erkennt man solche Fakes wie
erkennt man z.B noch den echten Olaf
Schubert woran erkenne ich dass es der
echte
ist woran erkennt man das echte es es
wird wirklich immer schwieriger ich
denke bei mir ist
es der Geruch
ja ja den kannst du jetzt nicht so in Z
D Tagen zusammenrühren das ist ja
wirklich über Jahre gereift das ist ja
eine
ein eine olfaktorische Melange aus pret
Pit aus ganz feiner Leberwurst
und braunenkohle nein aber ja ich denke
der Deutsche ist automatisch so ein
bisschen ha ki ki künstliche Intelligenz
ist gefährlich also intuitiv verlassen
wir uns lieber auf die natürliche
Blödheit aber man muss halt genau
hinschauen ja also beim Kanzler was er
da angeblich gesagt hat über die
Bildzeitung hab ich natürlich sofort
gemerkt das ist eine KI ja finde Aage
des normalen kanzl war ja viel zu
konkret und ja man muss eben gerade beim
Kanzler Scholz hinschauen am besten
zweimal hinschauen und bis ich nicht aus
zweiter Quelle überprüft habe bis dahin
gilt bei mir die
unscholzvermutung ich so mit dem und dem
hab ich gemerkt hab ich gemerkt schön
Olaf Schubert meine Damen und
Herren
ha die Leute ich wollte euch nur um ein
kleines Abo bitten einfach anklicken
macht's gut
na los na los du scheißpferd
hey